but first we're going to go there
what is going on with the president of
the united states joe biden
seriously what is wrong what is going on
here
we the american people you deserve
answers
he barely has any public events his
vice president kamala harris is taking
solo calls with world leaders
that would be the commander-in-chief's
job joe reportedly starts getting ready
for
bed after a little milky around 7 p.m
he's the first president in modern
history that has not held an official
press conference
in his first 48 days and during the rare
occasion
that biden does actually appear in front
of the cameras
usually to bypass congress and totally
abandon
a co-equal branch of government that
being the legislative branch
his team quickly shuts down any and all
questions
and they go to bars and tone or they
hurry joe away from the public eye
or just turn off the feed completely as
we saw last week
take a look at what happened earlier
today
if they want to give a wave i see you
yeah
and then we also we need you
and then
[Applause]
let's go you guys come on come on let's
go
okay why is his staff continuing to hide
president biden
what do they know you we have a right to
know
and more importantly what did they know
about joe biden during the campaign
who knew what and when and was something
of great importance to we the american
people covered up
according to a new book from two
mainstream media journalists
one at nbc the other at the hill not
exactly
members of the vast right-wing
conspiracy the
biden campaign utilized get this their
words not mine
put your dumb uncle in the basement
strategy that's
because the people surrounding joe biden
knew
that the real joe biden was his
campaign's biggest liability now of
course at the time
we frequently we did report on his very
strange
basement bunker campaign we did question
why a presidential candidate
would be in hiding for weeks on end
disappear for days
in ahead of a debate or some big event
or
his speech at the democratic national
convention
of course it was virtual i'm not a
doctor i'm not playing doctor
but we have pointed out what are obvious
and visible cognitive struggles
we continue to do so after his
inauguration but for some reason after
the inauguration
the immediate mob i didn't care what i
was saying initially
during the campaign that he looked weak
frail and was struggling cognitively
then joe becomes president
then the immediate mob became outraged
that you're truly yours truly
and by my coverage now i responded by
just playing example
after example after example of joe
struggling
mightily and regularly and then gave the
media mob
the tape that was necessary to make
their own decisions then they decided it
was best not to fight with me
on what was clear as day so they feigned
indignation
and that has now largely subsided
because anyone with eyes to see
and ears to hear you can clearly tell
that joe biden is struggling
and sadly it is only getting worse take
a look
i want to thank the the
former general i keep calling in general
my
my the guy who runs that outfit over
there
uh i want to make sure we thank the
secretary
representatives uh cheryl
shirley jackson lee al green sylvia
garcia
lizzie pinelli excuse me
panel and uh what am i doing here for
secretary of health and education
service i nominated
javier baccaria you know
javier bashir excuse me if donald hump
donald trump is re-elected
freudian slip it's not shirley
it's sheila jackson lee and by the way
what am i doing here
i wake up in the morning i turn to jail
what am i doing here
it's not the first time he suggested oh
i lost my place hang on i
they gave me no cards my name is joe
my wife's name is jill i live at 1600
pennsylvania avenue
that's how weak he appears we have shown
you tape of him in 2012
and 2016 and today and there is a
dramatic
visible decline that person is supposed
to be the commander-in-chief
the leader of the free world and he
can't even remember the name of his own
secretary of defense
or where the secretary of defense works
joe
that would be the pentagon his name is
lloyd
austin it's not that hard to remember
this is getting scary not because i say
so
you can disagree with me all you want
but the entire world is watching
and yes they are seeing what we have
apparently bravely been willing to say
that others are thinking
one headline sky news australia quote
joe biden struggles to name his defense
secretary another
quote never before has the leader of the
free world
been so cognitively compromised now
if that's what our allies are reporting
i can only
imagine and frankly am fearful of what
our enemies may think and we have a lot
of enemies
a lot of hostile regimes a lot of
hostile actors like
vladimir putin the muellers in iran the
president of china
kim jong-un all hostile actors hostile
regimes
and now you better believe that they're
actively
watching very closely and no doubt would
try to capitalize
if they see biden's apparent weaknesses
now meanwhile back here at home i'm not
the only one in america seeing this
a brand new poll by rasmussen shows
half the country half 50 percent
is now worried that joe biden is not
physically or mentally up to the job
that's half the country
it's not just sean hannity we've just
been willing to say it
earlier than others because i guess
maybe others were being polite
or they were too afraid to say it and
late night by the way
television the trump-hating comics they
say they're struggling to find
material uh about biden to talk about
really that's probably only because of
your pure political bias
and rage against trump and it's also why
your shows are mostly failing
look at this poll today only 34 percent
of americans are very confident that
biden is
physically and mentally capable of being
president
this would be a crisis in confidence
with poll numbers like those
a typical administration what they would
do
is they would send out the
commander-in-chief for a lengthy press
conference
to prove to the american people and to
the world
that our president is healthy engaged
energetic uh has full mental acuity and
full mental fitness
but the biden administration is doing
the opposite
you're at no press conferences scheduled
yet in fact the biden administration
hasn't even scheduled a joint address to
congress
which is supposed to happen every single
year watch this
is the president chosen a date yet or
working with congress on a joint address
to congress and what's that going to
look like as far as being virtual or in
person
uh i don't have any update on that for
you and certainly as soon as we have a
date confirmed we are looking forward to
doing a joint address we're working
through that with congress
our focus now is on the address the
president will be delivering on thursday
night during his first primetime address
he'll talk about covid what we've
been through as a country and what the
path forward looks like and we'll focus
on
the next address once we get through
that and we'll circle back about that
date for you
any day now see what's happening here
they're clearly trying to buy
time they absolutely know that joe biden
is struggling cognitively
and by the way they know he is a walking
and talking liability joe biden can
barely read from a teleprompter as we
have been witnessing in recent weeks
or even remember the name of a cabinet
member that is standing right next to
him
or even remember the words endowed by
our
thing no it's not the creator that's god
the creator of
everything he loses his focus constantly
clearly struggling with names and
numbers in particular
and at times even days of the week he
even utters
well now a couple of times what the hell
what the hell am i doing here what the
hell
oh now will joe practice all day
tomorrow and thursday for his big
teleprompter speech on covet on thursday
evening
yes will he plow through it odds are
highly likely he will plow through it
they will put in the time
they will practice they will pump him
full of let's see
coffee let's energy drinks whatever he
needs
all the caffeine he'd want but that does
not explain away
everything else we all see it daily
now i have a theory on how this is all
going to play out
uncharacteristically for now i'm going
to keep that
to myself i will share it in due time in
the meantime
one important question must be addressed
who is in charge
who's running the show here is it kamala
is it ron claim
is it susan rice barack obama some
combination
of those people pelosi and schumer do
they see it
every single democrat needs to be asked
do they
see joe struggling cognitively
it is a legitimate question it's a
question the democrats and the media mob
had no trouble
asking about ronald reagan in 1984 the
age question
they had no problem raising these issues
with john mccain
when he was running in 2008 the age
issue
because it's not the guy now fast asleep
at 1600 pennsylvania avenue
that's not the same guy i remember just
four short years ago